on a l'impression d'être déchu de la
métropole il phare suffit dans des cas
comme ça ce qui prime c'est le dialogue
ces deux hommes étaient gens autour
d'une table j'ai pas que ça va se passer
pour la suite mais là c'est vraiment des
oies
[Musique]
et l'ensemble des travailleurs dans tous
les secteurs d'activités qui sont
mobilisés podium non à l'obligation
vaccinale non au passage météo je suis
là en tant que soignant en tant que
individus qui revendique le droit de
faire au choix de ce qu'il prend comme
médicament et que c'était le choix et
qu'on respecte mon choix et qu'on
respecte le choix de tous ceux aussi qui
ont décidé de ne pas céder à bâtir
[Musique]
c'est désolant ce délai pages à leurs
propres talents roller mais il ne devait
pas faire agir de cette façon
oui
[Musique]
m
pour
peut-être la défiance de la parole de
l'état de l'engagement d'états et ça ça
fait écho finalement au scandale de la
pollution sur le chlordécone vous savez
ce pesticide qui a été utilisée jusqu'en
1993 aux antilles guadeloupe et
martinique
alors qu'il était interdit partout
ailleurs sous la pression des lobbys et
qui aujourd'hui est soupçonné de
provoquer nombre de cancers nombreuses
maladies puisque il y a encore des
traces dans dans les terres dans les
terres de l'île
depuis quelques mois la tout augmenté
dans les magasins tout tout tout
augmenter en plus du prix de l'essence à
ses shows il s'impose et donne rien il
ya pas de solution pour les jeunes
[Musique]
et